Zalando is a leading European company
Online Clothing Store
And is now on its way to becoming a multi-service platform for the fashion world
The company started its work in Berlin
We have offices in many European cities
We are currently active in 15 European countries
We offer 1,500 brands on our electronic platform for clothing and fashion
70% of website visits come from mobile devices
So we're trying to deliver innovative experiences on mobile devices
For our users
We also launched Image Search and Barcode Scanner
To reduce the differences between
Watch online fashion and watch it without internet
We also have certain features, such as
Synchronize the desired commodity list
Which provide a consistent experience on many platforms
High quality application
Can attract the client of course
We invested a lot to improve the user experience
And improve the quality of our Android apps
Our app installs increased by 6% per month
We received about 40% of our Android app installs
Of free traffic through the search engine
We also recorded an increase in the permanent value of our products
Which we measure per user
And an increase of 15% in the last quarter of the year
We have been working in multiple directions
To improve application quality
We conducted a comprehensive restructuring
To strengthen the technical aspects
We also take advantage of the multiple test information we have
In addition to test information efficiency improvements
To check the quality of the app in each version
There are multiple tools in the Google Play console
Help us ensure the quality of the app
There are initial testing, pilot testing and pilot release reports
The new version control panel is a powerful tool
To improve app distribution
It also gives us all the data
Through a set of metrics such as promotions
Breakdowns and assessments
This allows us to closely monitor the performance of our applications
Since quality has been improved
Application start time was reduced by approximately 30%
Average daily crashes were reduced
Up to 90%
Ratings were improved from 4.3 to 4.4
Indicating a growing user satisfaction
We have put forward a lot of investments to develop
Experience and improve usage for our Android app users
We have made many important achievements in that area
As a Product Manager this increases my enthusiasm and desire
Offering a great experience for our Android app users.